Scott another game that's like not
really a game quote unquote but one that
I think all three of us were really
positive on as well as Pete Mary pretty
much took the game spot office like by a
stealthy storm we're talking about ABS
ooh yeah so this wonder a lot of
people's radar so before we get into
your opinion about in your review with
or their sonar nice Oh was trying to set
up a scholar wouldn't yes is a class
yeah help myself I'm a terrible human
you all hate me now anyway it wasn't
like I've seen like in the comments
echoed the dolphin jokes yeah even
though it's not a dolphin it's not
anything like cut the dolphins just
under water but anyway so tell us like
what abs you is in a nutshell if you can
sure so it's basically it's an
underwater exploration game it's very
much like journey so there's no dialogue
that the characters don't really have
names there's no even real context it's
just you sort of wake up in the middle
of the ocean and you begin your forward
journey it's it's a very linear
experience but you're also can kind of
explore at your own pace for the
majority of the game so you can really
enjoy the sea life that's all very
believable like all of the the
ecosystems you interact with their like
happening around you and and just kind
of subsist without you even influencing
them it's just you can watch and enjoy
all the stuff happening around you it's
a very like I think the way I put in my
reviews it's a very profoundly peaceful
experience but there is more of a story
the more you play you start to uncover
different aspects of the world and you
realize there is kind of that everything
you want covers alluding to this sort of
narrative and the more you play the more
you understand so it actually becomes a
really moving and and like just kind of
timeless experience and it goes in some
really surprising directions it evolves
in ways that I really didn't see coming
and I and that's really all I want to
say about it no it's one of those really
difficult to discuss games because it is
relatively short I only took me about
four hours and I was really taking my
time so the more you talk about it the
more you risk kind of spoiling the
enjoyment but I'm spice to say it is
more than an ocean life simulator even
if it really is a really great ocean
life simulator for a lot of the
experience yeah it's weird cuz even
though there are kind of spoilers even
like talking to other people the office
is kind of hard to describe like what
the spoilers are it's a very kind of
like
it's it's like you compared at the
journey a lot did you talk about that
like the comparisons with that or yeah
totally people who have been reading
previously games probably know that this
this game is actually made by journeys
art director it's a new studio giant
squid but it's several team members from
who worked on either journey or flower
of uterine games of that kind of ilk
somehow I'm hoser as well Austin wintry
yeah music is really fantastic can get
into that because I was a big partier of
you as well yeah for sure um but yes I
mean like I said the it doesn't it
doesn't have journeys multiplayer which
is a bit of a shame i mean i think part
of what made journey such a powerful
experience for most players was that
that moment of walking up to another
character in the world realizing that
it's another human and and you can't
actually speak to each other but you can
still kind of communicate like that was
such an original and interesting idea
and and so powerful in the context of
that world where you did feel kind of
isolated and lonely so this game does
not have multiplayer but it kind of
fills that void in a different way and
and like i was describing earlier it
shares a lot of just structural
similarities to journey in that it just
linear it is brief it is wordless it is
primarily about exploration it's
relatively light on mechanics so there's
no there's no combat you can't even
actually died in the game i mean i
actually tried i messed around to see if
like I could find a way to fail and you
you really can't but that I think just
speaks to the type of experience it is
it's kind of like a beautiful and
meditative experience more so than like
a traditional you know video game in in
like the Mario or you know shooter sense
or anything like that yeah you kind of
touched on it but I'm there a couple
times throughout it when I thought I was
like it's lurking into the territory i
feel like it just trying to gamify
things whether it's through like puzzles
or like collectibles but it never was
too difficult or too kind of clawing
that i got in the way of the experience
it was trying to be i found i liked it
just for like how peaceful and like zen
it is and totally like when they first
announced i thought it was just like a
scuba diving diving simulator before I
really looked into who it was and what
not not like a hardcore simulator but
like I have a lot of background scuba
diving oddly enough and so I really yeah
I just like this setting like the
setting and like itself was initially
appealing but you know you start getting
too though you start discovering new
creatures like you know like these
different barracuda or I don't know if
these
actual like real I don't think these are
scientifically um I think they are two
to a degree i mean like so you want one
of the mechanics the games you can sort
of cling to larger animals and slide
around on them and when you do like
their name will appear in the bottom
right corner and it's you know it's not
like they're Latin scientific genius you
know is your sperm but yeah it'll tell
you what the animal is and it seems like
they went to some effort to ensure that
the animals looked and behaved in ways
that correlated with the real animal so
yeah I mean I don't know that this is
gonna be like an educational tool it's
not quite at that level but certainly it
seems like they paid attention to the
species they were including what they
look like and how they act and how they
interact so to some extent I think it is
like somewhat scientifically accurate I
don't know that that was like yeah maybe
not as far as you'll find like this kind
of orca whale alongside an angler fish
at this depth or anything yeah it does
if they are like the artwork itself is
very despite the fact like I think you
call the wind waker ask it's also very
that they are like their detailed
creatures despite the fact that it's
kind of a minimalistic look um but also
you know like it is tough to talk about
because you can't get into like who you
are or like what like what is going on
at all whether there is something going
on which is frustrating but yeah right
but it's it's also like I guess like the
number one thing for me I was worried
about ever since like games became 3d
swimming has been one of games big
problems so before like I heard you and
Pete come in after you had reviewed NP
had played it as well I was worried as
saying I don't want to devote two hours
or however long it is to like struggling
with swimming controls but it turns out
that's not a problem here no not at all
the swimming pool is fantastic like
better than probably any 3d game that I
can remember and I think a lot of that
can be attributed to the control scheme
which actually is very close like a
racing games control scheme when you
think about it it's sort of odd but but
it works makes perfect sense you're
you're using our to like the right
trigger to swim forward so matter which
direction the cameras facing if you hold
our to your character just swims forward
which is great because that lets you
kind of look around and enjoy the
environment and then use the left stick
to sort of change direction and then
is so fluid but you will just kind of
flip or twist in whatever way and it
looks really graceful and it always is
very responsive to your input so the
swimming ends up feeling really
fantastic again probably better than any
game that I can remember mm-hmm and then
you throw in like the boost mechanic
where you have to kind of like
rhythmically tap the X button to build
up boost and like just that can be
really exhilarating kind of maneuver
through objects in the environment where
the breech out of the water and do flips
and you can get fish to follow you and
again this sounds like kind of silly but
it's actually like really enjoyable and
again it fits with sort of the peaceful
nature of the game but it gives it a
little more energy and a little more
kind of fun and active and you know it
gives the game some gameplay to fall
back on yeah can you talk about the did
mention in your review the the score by
Austin winter you think you said it like
it adapts to the actual what's happening
yeah so what's what's really cool is
that mean again it's a linear game so as
you move forward you can kind of at
least when I started paying attention to
it I realized that it's not like oh I'm
in area a therefore song a plays and
then I went to area be so song be
started it's more like as you move the
music will adapt to like sort of where
you are and what you're doing and it
seems to do that on the fly like it's so
subtle you don't even really notice it's
just they're adding this kind of like
emotional texture undercurrent
underneath the experience and it doesn't
ever really call attention to itself it
just dynamically shifts and adjusts and
stitches itself together in these
different ways to provide that that
texture to like propel you through the
experience and keep you in a particular
mood that matches whatever is happening
around you it's like so elegantly done
it's yeah you don't even really notice
unless you're really paying attention
yeah the momentum it's specific parts
you know you get into these faster paced
parts the momentum of the score
parallels that of the gameplay and
whatnot which is a really nice feeling
because then after a while you have like
these schools of fish swimming along
with you you have these like big clouds
of fish that you go through you there's
no there's one part yeah I don't want to
spoil it there are there there are
specific moments that like I was talking
to Pete Brown about and I was saying
this part was great and like I told Mary
the same thing about certain parts so
there are memorable moments in this game
but it strikes me as this singular
experience someone something we're all
curious about and uh dodsworth and seven
in the twitch chat had asked if there
was multiplayer akin to journey's or is
this just strictly single-player it's a
purely purely
single player um yeah and in a way when
you when you play the game you
understand why again that this one of
the frustrations about the game that
like you don't want to devote so much
about it but it is the kind of game
that's best enjoyed on your own just
like put on headphones sit by yourself
just like chill out and play this game
and just let it let it kind of wash over
you man mm-hmm I don't want to get to
like hippy Zen about it because that's
not that's not really who I am but I
still found this game like really
cathartic and just calming and beautiful
and just like exactly what I think a lot
of people might need it's like an
amazing palate cleanser between games
like I don't know overwatch or something
really competitive really high stakes
like it's something really great to like
just go do this instead yeah and it's
where it looks like I think in my
current like habit of playing games
right now if I'm reviewing stuff i'll
play something for about two hours and
get up for like ten minutes if I need to
or you know like just maybe like fun but
if it's the weekend I'll play for two
hours go and do something come back and
finish something off later this is like
the perfect length for me to just sit
down one sitting literally without
getting up and like Jake and I both
played last night and we talked about it
afterward but that was a thing I didn't
even want to stop playing because it
wasn't it wasn't like pulling me thru at
a breakneck pace but it was the same
time just such a calming thing and like
you said it's just what I needed I just
beat dhoom the weekend before I've been
playing over watch these fast paced kind
of just like hella shooters and then
like that's why I was kind of excited
about it because I love journey I loved
you know like gone home excited for
Tacoma fulbright companies other game
coming out I don't know Jake what did
you think about like abs ooh overall
like did it line up with your
expectations of what it was going to be
or without spoiling anything obviously
did it become something altogether new I
actually didn't really have expectations
what I knew about this game and I knew
it had a lot to do with old people who
are people who worked on journey but I
mean I then I heard Pete talk about and
then I heard you talk about it I was
like all right I'm gonna play this game
and i did and i thought it was
phenomenal i think what i have to say is
that if you're deciding between batman
or ab 0 i'd get ab 0 yeah it's nice that
they're both kind of like bite size but
um absolu I think did encompass like a
little broader thing you know without
something to pompous and artistic about
it there are like
deeper things you can glean from it
whether you want to or not if you don't
want to it's just a it's just a very
fluid fun thing to do like I know I've
like I kind of waited into the comments
on accident and like oh yeah yeah majin
it's one of those one of those things
for people saying it's not a game yeah
it's this it's so joyless which is not
argue I don't want to bring up the
weather these are games argument right
now those people just bum me out so much
just like if you're not into it that's
fine you don't need to be it's like
there's a whole world like we have dark
souls we have over watched we have fury
we have a head Lander we have all these
games that either are explicitly trying
to be old games or like the modern
equivalent of those games and are
challenging and skillful like all that
stuff is amazing just let this exists as
well like we have room for all this
stuff like chill out guys it's a
beautiful experience if you don't want
that totally cool you don't need to be
like a joyless jerk and try to ruin it
for everybody else that's all I'll say
and I don't want you to do it I'm sorry
I just had a whole morning of like
people being angry in the comments Oh No
shaking my head and getting depressed
yeah I'm sorry I bring that up no it's
available with these types again people
will always want to have that
conversation this isn't a game and it's
just it's exhausting every time it is
just shirking those definitions can help
us create more for the media my thinking
but again that's a different argument
and kinda I don't wanna get into right
now I don't think anybody wants to see
it into it what would you say that maybe
I shouldn't say I was gonna say no I
don't care go for it oh I I mean if it
plays so well like you play us so well
like I feel in the game that that the
argument should be over after that
because like the swimming unlike what
Mike was saying like I my least favorite
thing in games is swimming usually like
the minute I dive underwater I'm like
great here we go but this like the
entire experience just like the swimming
just feels so streamlined so great and
like breaching up out of the water and
one hmm it's exhilarating oh actually
one small thing did you guys figure out
the boost mechanic like the triple boost
yeah okay cuz like I wasn't paying
attention they told me so I just kept
like furiously is happening but if you
do the tempo the 123 he does the the
kick and then the mermaid and then the
just pull on boost which is yeah it
feels in flippers yeah one thing I
didn't figure out that Rob handler we
found out was you can do cannonballs
like if you breach out of the water and
hit the circle button I like 10
I saw that like I saw him knew how are
you doing that I thought that was really
cool yeah yeah there's all kinds of like
little just nuances and worked into the
mechanics they're really important but
like it's cool that they're there yeah
do either you feel the need to go back
or like do you watch him God yeah I
already did I already went back and like
plate halfway through it again okay yeah
I'm gonna play this weekend I think
again yeah for me I fully expect this to
be one of those games that I play like
once a year like I just want to go back
to that world and spend time okay yeah I
think I'm kind of different from you
guys and it was a time and place thing
for me like my lights were off last
night I'd it was just a long day and I
just finished it and it was that's all I
need it's not that I don't like it at
all i really like it i completely agree
you gave it a nine out of ten you know
like we were talking like what should a
score be but after a while it's in one
of those games it's hard to a sign of
score but I completely get it it's gonna
be different for everybody for me or
just one thing I wanted to just get out
the music was great the the art was
great the actual like way you move
through it in the way it kind of tells
it's weird like simplistic story again
without going to spoilers but it does go
into unlike territory might not expect
or maybe you do I don't know depending
on your kind of what you're expecting a
guess which that's always difficult to
balance with what it really is but yeah
it was a surprise for me yeah I probably
won't go back to like I said but I I
really enjoyed like that bite size
experience I think it was just what I
need I think it's like you settled what
a lot of people need right now yeah I
would hope that people just give it a
chance like I think people will be very
surprised at how it affects them like
just affects their move it affects their
emotions it's just that kind of game
that will get in your head and like the
best way and just kind of wash over you
and like other things just stopped
mattering it really is just like
meditation in Game form and it's
beautiful I sincerely recommend
everybody try it cool yeah me too I
think Jake you could probably support
that and and Mary I don't know if Rob
liked it I think she did you seem to be
enjoying it i don't know that he beat it
but he seemed to be enjoying it when I
when I walked over and he was playing
cool well that's absa you can read scott
Butterworth's review it's a 9 out of 10
on gamespot go delve into the minutia on
our website and let us know what you
think in the comments below